on dit souvent que les jeunes
martiniquais ne ferons rien ou bien
qu'il parle t'on métropole qu'est la
connaissance pas et en fait j'ai voulu
montrer donc avec mes collègues que non
en fait on est là et que on a des
projets qu'on sait les mener à bien que
nos projets ils sont viables et ils sont
réellement une opportunité non seulement
pour nous mais en plus ce coup le
développement de la martinique
et c'est ce qu'on a voulu montrer que la
jeunesse martiniquaise et lila est
toujours là ça équipe remplie de
péripéties mais de belles péripéties
parce qu'on apprend en fait deux de nos
erreurs et on apprend également tombe on
se relève et on fait mais on fait mieux
après est ce que vous avez appris et
j'ai appris que tout d'abord pour
obtenir ce qu'on veut il faut déjà avoir
la détermination ce n'est pas la
motivation qu'il faut on ira plus jamais
jusqu'au bout et même si on a la
motivation contre l'épreuve à venir on
va quand même se plier face à l'épreuve
mais il faut savoir justement compter à
ce moment là tout ce qui nous entoure et
donc mes collègues j'ai pu compter sur
mes collègues on a tous encouragé donc
j'ai appris la cohésion l'esprit
d'équipé j'ai appris à avoir confiance
non seulement moi même mais également
dans les autres et j'ai aussi appris que
il ya une grande fierté dans ce qu'on a
réussi quelque chose qu'on a mené à bien
qu'on a mené soi-même en fait donc j'ai
appris à vivre toutes ces choses qui
sont extraordinaires on a voulu montrer
que
les jeunes hommes en tunique est capable
d'accomplir de belles choses et d'avoir
des projets innovants pour mettre en
valeur à la matinée qui ça m'a beaucoup
aidé à combattre ma timidité et j'ai
réalise ça m'a permis d'aller de l'avant
en fête et de ne plus me renfermer ou
d'avoir peur aux fêtes mais vraiment d'y
aller et j'ai eu des collègues
merveilleuse qui m'ont aussi beaucoup
appris à avoir confiance en moi et à y
aller au fait des jeunesses du boot ça
raconte des jeunes qui réussissent c'est
ça oui exactement alors non seulement
des jeunes qui réussissent mais des
jeunes qui ont connu des échecs mais qui
savent comment se relever qui trouve le
moyen de se relever et jeunesse du goût
de fête veut faire passer comme message
que même si on est jeune on est capable
d'accomplir de grandes choses et quand
bien même on tourne mais on peut aussi
se relever mais je suis quelqu'un qui
parle pas beaucoup en général
donc j'ai appris que mon jeu peut aussi
pousser repousser mes limites dans la
communication
notamment et bien que je peux je suis
capable que je peux le faire ça m'a
donné du courage pour affronter la suite
et même de la confiance